ensuite quelques façons c'est tout ça
qui est en cause dans cette affaire
est-ce que je suis pas vous demander si
vos ancêtres n'étaient pas très
phallocratique dans la mesure où
justement disposer de ce langage qui
faisait qu'il n'était pas compris de
leurs épouses et aux voyez bien que
c'était pour une supériorité et bien le
fait aussi
d'après toujours votre livre que les
hommes finalement laissait les femmes
travailler très durement beaucoup plus
que même question d'ethnie et il y a
aussi des traits communs toute l'afrique
noire
c'est vrai il y a un nom des hommes il
ya un mode des femmes est bien ou des
enfants il ya un langage qui tient à
l'initiation mais il ya aussi une
différence des styles je me rappelle
quand le roi d'ici le quart du temps de
mon enfance le roi en sérère était un
protectorat quand le roi ly sin venez
voir mon père et que je les écoutais ce
qui me frappe et c c'est la courtoisie
et on attend l'ailé dans sa sobriété et
ne parlez pas comme des femmes et encore
moins et comme les enfants et le dans la
maison opéré d
un propriétaire terrien nous étions à
peu près 60 personnes dans la maison lui
il habitait dans la villa au sens romain
du mois et à droite et à gauche il y
avait les jb c'est n'est ce pas où
habitez les femmes les enfants et la
domesticité du matin au soir il y avait
une sorte de rituel de cérémonie et
l'encodage pour les hommes un langage
pour les femmes la maj pour le matin
langage pour l'après midi donc il ya des
prix généraux de la cité des oiseaux
qu'il ya des traits particuliers aussi
par exemple jusqu'à présent quand je
vais chez les mandingues
je sais que ce sont des femmes et qui
sont alléchants qui travaillent le plus
les hommes ce sont des commerçants
donc les yeux de monsieur oui mais ce
sont des commerçants
ce sont des artistes se savait palabras
vous voyez il y a des traits propres aux
piments d'un mais ce que votre femme
vous allez continuer